[Musik]
nach 0 45 hallo ihr lieben ich wollte
mich bei euch bedanken für 10.000
abonnenten mittlerweile sind wir schon
verfällt von 500 aber umso mehr freut
mich dass so schnell wachsen und
angesicht des abonniert haben ja auch
auf feuchter könig zu verlosen
wenn ich mal ich verlor drei visual
studio korea ihr habt vielleicht termine
dafür schon gesehen hat habe ich jetzt
vor kurzem hochgeladen und das nike nach
wunsch also ihr könnt eure namen oder
den namen wird wenige beschenken möchte
dann kommt hier auch der überraschung
beschritten zu klein
euer name und das für mich dass wir noch
nie sagt aber nicht nur was nicht ganz
glücklich mit dem thema backen zu tun
haben dass sie so eine art wundertüte
sein also ihre content fangen und seid
dann überrascht was sich darin versteckt
und teilen könnt ihr ganz einfach ihr
wolltet natürlich abonnent des kanals
beim einloggen in diesem video hier
leiten und schreiben wir in die
kommentare während video oder möchtest
rezept ihr schon nach gemacht hat oder
welche tier vorher nachzumachen macht 1
nach wenig nach gemacht habt dann auch
nicht sagen wollten sich einfach
ansteckend war und dann könnt ihr noch
in die kommentare und mieter zu
schreiben welcher name hier drauf stehen
also wie gesagt ich verkündige gehindert
dann auch hier in dem video und verbockt
also schaut auf jeden fall mal rein
das gewinnspiel geht's genau zehn tage
sand und dann werdet ihr unternehmen wie
durch ein ende box in form lernt und
wenn ihr jetzt auch diese haben wollen
und von gefüllt mit einer überraschung
dann macht auf jeden fall mit beim
gewinnspiel und ich sag's bis zum
nächsten mal auf diese skizzen
[Musik]